well my t-shock is where there's now A
bertia Hern of course hello to you Mr
Ahern it's always great to see you
thanks for joining us when did you know
that you'd achieved a great thing
well I think about five minutes after we
signed it um I finally believed that the
uh the parties agreed because it was it
was a long haul and uh I suppose we had
been up and down uh so many you know
good bits and bad bits and in the end in
the end the last few days were hectic
and about four times I think we thought
we were there and about four times we
talked we'd failed so it it was not
until that that meeting uh where we all
sat around the table together and George
Mitchell finally asked people to give
their endorsement
S5 on a good Friday if that agreement
hadn't been signed by then
what would that have meant for that
weekend in the province
I think what would have happened Kay is
that there would have been a huge
disappointment but all the security
indications at the time were uh that we
would quickly
um revert back to the old ways of
violence again and um you know we had
seen that the previous Christmas when
there was a break at the Christmas
period and we'd seen violence from from
both sides so uh you know and and the
big concern I had at the time thinking
about it over the last few weeks was you
know the trouble started in the 60s and
there were two real attempts to try and
find a solution once in 74. that failed
and the next room was 85 11 years later
and when when that failed then we had to
wait 13 years more so the difficulty was
that we could have been in for another
decade and and that was certainly the
the security
um the briefings at the time that we
would revert back to the past again so
thankfully that didn't happen thankfully
we've had 25 years of of peace and
there's has been some low-level violence
and there's been some you know
high-level violence where some killings
but not not a lot thank God and
unfortunately the political position has
not been a stable okay it it's um that's
been up and down we've had a number of
protracted delays in the institutions uh
in Belfast and we're in the middle of
one of those at the moment so hopefully
we'll get to the end of that later on
this year yeah but you let me take you
back a quarter of a century again now
though if I may other conversations
during those protracted negotiations
um that uh you never shared with others
well I suppose they've been they've been
fairly well aired but you know there
were certainly difficult actually there
are things you find out all the time
um for example I I I did a podcast there
recently one of the radio stations here
where I I tried to to go back and
interview all those that were alive that
were involved
um 25 years ago and of course I spoke to
George Mitchell and Bill Clinton and
Tony Blair that you've mentioned and all
the other party leaders and I spoke to
John hume's son but he gave me an
account of you know that when John Hume
uh went to meet the provisional Ira Army
Council you know how how that happened
and the fact that he was driven around
in a van for for a day and which was
quite amazing and then I I also learned
from David trimble's wife that on the
Tuesday uh of the the final that was
Holy Week was just a few days before and
the deadline Good Friday and that David
Trimble had actually written to the
Prime Minister saying that he couldn't
make the deal and he was really going to
get out of here so you pick up bits all
the time that that I didn't know
did mention Mo molam how big a role did
momoland play um God Rest her soul
um very unconventional woman wasn't she
she was she mole mole was as tough as as
anyone would you want to have mentioned
because she she was tough and but she
was great fun and great sense of Goomer
um but you know she she didn't take any
nonsense from anybody and particularly
men who tried to be a bit bully boys and
and you know she she would kick the the
slippers off and put the feet up and
when she got really mad she she'd take
that time she was suffering from cancer
and so from bad with cancer she told her
hair piece off and she gave them a
tongue lesson but you know she was Brave
she went into the prisons at a crucial
time she went in and spoke to the uh to
the blindness prisoners to calm them
down and explain where we were at and
that was a really big decision uh it
wasn't one that was advised to her and
but she felt that it was a good thing to
do I don't think of your take 100 people
I think 99 of them wouldn't have done
that but it was the right thing to do
when I supported her and it was very
helpful
what were the standout moments for you
particularly I mean
um Tony Blair not a time for sound bites
of course but he could feel the hand of
history on his shoulder what about you
yeah I I I I think um you know one of
the the memories I always have is who
you know the the last night or two there
were all night sessions and he went into
the negotiating rooms uh and you know
you had half of the teams were literally
asleep on their desk
um and the other half were absolutely
jaded and you know walking out into the
into the gardens were there but I
suppose that the one I always remember
at about five in the morning on Good
Friday and I decided I needed some mayor
and I just had finished a long session
with Tony Blair with Mark McGuinness the
late Mark McGinnis and Jerry Adams
um and I went out to a door I I thought
it was safe enough I saw
um a gardener so I pushed the security
door and walked out to to be met by uh
three or four
um or you see men with sub machine guns
anyway they they badly decided I wasn't
a terrorist so I got through that but I
did get a price yeah I bet you did I bet
you did 30 years of violence before that
three and a half thousand lives lost how
it takes a special kind of politician
and as you said there were several of
you that couldn't talk peace with
terrorists
yeah it was you know it was horrendous
time in in the north all the time I was
in school and you know from 68 I was in
my last year and second level and you
know it went on and on and on and you
know nobody really ever got tired of it
because one event was even more
horrendous than the other and every day
was the bombings that well there were
nearly 40 000 people seriously injured
not to mind the the trade houses haven't
under died and you know the damage the
the buildings they you know just the
null tourism no Investments you know
very little happening young people going
abroad for their education rather than
staying at home like it was a horror
story and um I I think in the end of the
day
there wasn't much option really to Tony
Blair and I followed the major
principles that effectively meant that
you couldn't engage in violence and be
involved in peace talks and you know
that was a bit of it you know gray area
we did our best to try and make sure the
violent stopped totally but you know
that that wasn't always possible so in
football terms we were given red cards
to anyone or any party that was
associated with anyone who was involving
for violence but it was the right thing
to have inclusive talks which pulled
everybody in including the parties that
had previously been involved with groups
of involving violence and to be
comprehensive in terms of the issues we
dealt with you know prisoners and
demilitarization of the north changing
the criminal justice system reform of
the policing there were all huge issues
and you know some of them we got very
right some of them not so right the
commission went on too long went down
for five years before we got that but
overall I think hey you know Northern
Ireland is a better place it's not
perfect there's still the outstanding
issues and um you know I suppose after
after so much violence it takes time and
of course I should all mentioned the
Legacy that the people who who lost
their lives and their families are still
trying to get Justice sure
um president uh Clinton made a big
difference 25 years ago can President
Biden get all sides around the table for
Stormont
I think you know his word said tonight
when he arrives in tomorrow
um will be important I think anywhere in
the world it it always be glad to
welcome the the president I think my
regret today is uh okay but that he
would have been I think
um addressing storming today and talking
to the politicians but Stormwind is in
suspension so I think that's a that
that's a big pity and he'll obviously
see the party leaders at a university
opening in Belfast tomorrow a tremendous
new University of Ulster wing and I'm
sure he'll talk to them there but you
know it's not it's not ideal there's
still still work to be done and you know
hopefully his words might help
politicians to to see some some new
light
okay just before I left you let's look
to the Future
um what
if I didn't Hearn how does
how does the size
I don't know about all of that I I get
an older okay and and
um but do you want to be president we'll
have to see how a play plays out but
anyway in the meantime we might
concentrate and trying to do all the
other things I'm involved in and it's a
few years away before that even arises
so I'll think about it then yeah it's
not a no is it um enjoy the next few
days
um
saving the knowledge that you are
brought about peace with others for the
last 25 years good on you thank you
thanks a lot Kate good to see you and
you too